c'est très compliqué de s'approprier
l'espace public au maroc quand on est
une femme
on
marcher seul dans la rue pendant de
longues heures et se faire des belles
balades au bord de la mer ou je ne sais
pas quoi
ce n'est pas possible si enfin voilà on
est quand même très très souvent
importuner et ça quelle que soit la
classe sociale pour le coup
une femme ne peut pas arriver chez elle
de bon matin et dire maman papa je suis
enceinte d'un mec
voilà et donc on va vivre en concubinage
et tout va bien
ça soulève la question des rapports
sexuels en dehors du mariage
évidemment ça ça soulève la question de
concubinage aussi et donc de ces
abandons d'enfants des femmes qui
meurent en couches parce qu'elle
accouche seule ou qu'elles doivent
apporter avortée par défaut ce d'ange
puisque les hôpitaux ne peuvent pas
aller prendre en charge puisque
l'avortement dans ces conditions là
voilà et illégale donc en fait
ouvrons le débat
si on n'en parle pas et si on ne trouve
pas de solution parce que d'accord il ya
ce que la religion dit comme toutes les
religions monothéistes comme quoi voilà
il faut rester vierge jusqu'au mariage
sauf que maintenant on fait face à un
problème social seulement il faut savoir
qu'au maroc la liberté fonctionne à
double vitesse et que la liberté se
négocie s'arrange en fonction de qui on
est d'où on vient et en fonction de
l'argent qu'on a plus on fait parti des
déshérités et plus on est écrasé par un
système qui est biaisé injuste skis pour
qu'il fonctionne comme un espèce de
rouleau compresseur sociale